[Music]  this is elsie  she's a komodo dragon  the largest species of lizard on earth  today  [Music]  females like elsie can grow to be six  feet long and males are known to reach  10 feet and weigh over 200 pounds  they are fierce hunters and can  incapacitate large prey like deer water  buffalo and on rare occasions human  beings  its bacterial-laced saliva often causes  fatal blood poisoning within 24 hours  the komodo dragon can consume up to 80  percent of its body weight in a single  feeding  native to five indonesian islands komodo  dragons are territorial and spend much  of their time alone  these fearsome predators face numerous  threats earthquakes volcanic activity  habitat loss and illegal poaching have  reduced the wild populations to only a  few thousand  this is the komodo dragon  you